patrick pour moi tu resteras toujours le
franchement le roi de la fête à la télé
toutes les émissions c'était que de la
fête c'est vrai donc ce soir je suis en
rien bah oui je sais on a décidé de te
faire un toc toc toc spéciale chansons
pour faire la fête
ouais je sais vous nous avez réclamé le
toc toc toc c'est jeudi aujourd'hui elle
c'est bon le jeu 10 mois pour moi c'est
l'avant dernier jour de la semaine parce
qu'après j'ai vendredi j'ai balances ton
pote et samedis et dimanches je suis que
sur les réseaux sociaux
donc voilà donc je t'ai rien mais je
suis quand même avec vous mais je sais
rien mais le week-end sur les réseaux
sociaux tube ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais c'est j'ai très peu de vie sains
c'est quand tu t'habilles comme ça un
moment tu sais que tu as pas le vilain
derrière allez on va accueillir le
premier toc toc toc c'est pas plus fort
toc toc toc
ah c'est quelqu'un qui était blessé ça
je sors qui est la cgil gilles qui
gilles diehl fait chaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mongi qui re marche
oui j'aurais ouais ça y est ça va mieux
là vous savez je sais ce qui vous à
faire marcher c'est quoi c'est le prime
de vendredi sur les mots je sais que ça
vous a relancé sa ma carrière surtout
non mais regardez comme il est beau il a
bien maigri il est beau sa jambe est et
ça va mieux ça ira mieux mais je peux
marcher déjà non mais s'ils font un gros
progrès très bon vous êtes prêt quand on
voit bien le piège de gonfler le le pied
le pied est dégonflé oui la tête mais
jamais de résurrection de moto j'ai eu
plein show facture talons j'avais eu
droit de la toucher à son pied sans
rigoler on dirait une grillade a cessé
alors bientôt envie de mettre des frites
à côté oui on vous donne mon pied quoi
voulez la faute aux mots clés alors je
préfère non que oui notre jeu l'est non
mais là faut te vois tu es beau tu paies
jeu déjà moi je suis pas fan des pieds
ouais mais non elle vient votre pied
sans rigoler c'est une cata c'était
fréquent mais voit son pied peut faire
un film d'horreur soir des play offs et
le prouveront le prochain vendredi 13
allez c'est parti
deuxième toc toc toc et bien sûr son
premier on va voir s'il y arrive à le
faire banny non mais alors je vais
t'expliquer juste un truc
en fait il faut que tu passes au toc toc
toc en même temps que tu toc toc toc
espèce de ramallah non mais alors vas-y
roffet voilà jan ake yan yan qui ya du
soleil et des nanas
[Applaudissements]
moi
non
miss france 2012
delphine est ce que tu te rappelles
qu'on s'est rencontrés chez patrick
sébastien tous les deux exactement la
première web j'étais invité je crois que
j'étais pas j'étais leur foi ou tu
m'avais fait un immense honneur je crois
que je n'ai pas 20 de l'émission et
delphine était invité ouais et il est là
qu on sait qu on s'est croisés pour la
première fois et on a fait une très très
belle photo tous les trois et ce à
partir de là qu'on a commencé à y font
tailler merci qui merci patrick c'est
vrai merci à combattre l'inertie perte
c'est vrai et c'est là que j'ai vu qui a
été très sympathique et a prôné reste en
contact et vecten en 2020 on s'est plus
vu non et finalement on s'est revus
après non on se voit tout le temps ouais
bah merci calme-toi quand même été très
belle mais là le comble fixe avait agi
allez c'est parti
toc toc toc alors toc toc quoi il n'y a
pas un peu plus viril
[Rires]
le mec est excédé à peine porte mais n'a
pas du tout envie que toc toc toc wii
qui est là alors à la hâte en jeu
reprend to my mind
je pense que tout le monde sait que
c'est maintenant
on a tort quand tu sais toi tu
reviendras en l'air dehors tu reviendras
tu ça laisse la place merci à l'est le
prochain os la toc toc toc tout le monde
c'est un guy séguin venir des voix comme
ça et là pas ce à quoi à la toc toc pour
rien et comprend rien tu vois pas que je
te dis qu'il a redit c'est cuit rené
lévy rené la coupe les os
[Applaudissements]
m
bonjour
ok
mnf versée donc ça ça c'est végé dream
ça c'est une vraie c'est comme ça et à
rien ça plutôt presque oui à l'évaluer
matin ça vaut son côté gazaoui ma valise
fais-moi bab la rade et mon bébé par
avec merci allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
en fait tu t'attaques break et là
c'était ce [ __ ] c'est qu'ils détestent
[ __ ] si vous imiter la pas voir tu vas
voir al ahly je crois qu'elle vous
imminent je peux y aller là alors on l'a
fait toc toc toc balibar tac qui est là
c'était ce [ __ ] mais pourquoi c'était
ce [ __ ] c'est scss que sinon ils ont
plein de gars van tets ski test mais
c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
pour la cour c'est la meilleure pour
l'instant ça va quoi quoi quoi l'état
patrick immédiat mais bon ça [ __ ] ça
change génial et morue des sardines pour
le roi de la mise en boîte
génial je ne fais pas partie c'était pas
si elle est belle on remet un
contentieux entre nous parce que quand
vous êtes déjà dragué tous les non pas
du tout quoi ils appellent ça te regarde
pas
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un bail
non666 skin séparé ne sera pas non c'est
pas vrai là c'est exactement son garçon
[Rires]
le coach m'a dit vas-y tu attaques et là
eva eva qui saturent
à
on va
ça vaut
[Applaudissements]
moi tu sors directement aux non c'est
bien celui-là d'or est allée au devant
de skagen avec nous elle adore ça se
passe dans la torre pascal gand une pub
à chaque fois et donne toi ça va on
dirait que c'est vraiment sa dernière
émission
oui elle sait qu'elle est sur le fil du
rasoir il se serait un nom mais faisant
que vous les faites tout en ce moment
oui il est innocent tout bas et je me
fais discrète comme ça vous vous oubliez
un peu vous faites pas trop discrète
parce que vous êtes payé quand même
allez on va passer au prochain
baby doc toc toc est là jean-michel mais
non mais c'est pas possible ça fait cinq
ans qu'on le fait ce jeu bordel
il est où la merde mais qu'est ce tu
fais là de leur goût j'ai été recalée
tout à l'heure a été rude
je crois que tu rentreras pas grave si
je crois moi ne rentrera pas et tu veux
l'audience mais les résidents comme l'a
dit jean mi octobre et la baraque baraki
barak que bouddha
faux
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
[Musique]
il accomplit de lui même il a compris de
l'huma me il ne reviendra pas dessus
allez c'est parti allez à ce jeu si vous
pouviez ne pas toucher la poignée de la
porte pour ne pas contaminer les autres
vous allez rentrer retraite le bas vous
m'avez dit rentrée alors qu'on n'a pas
fait le tac tac tac
oh là là là mais c'est pas possible
c'est là la gastro à l'attaqué la tête
aussi
hélas les semis leslie qui l'est
[Applaudissements]
waouh
à
[Applaudissements]
oh
merci c'est pas mal on voit qu'à la
partie des missions de vue du joueur il
est tout autre ça fait deux jours
qu'elle est allongée chez elle un peu
vous étiez malade ça va mieux et devrait
tout va mieux tout est rentré dans
l'ordre
tout est rentré dans l'ordre la cervelle
tout va bien d'accord non mais si elle
était allongée sur le trône sous peu
sur 10
allez allez le prochain vide avec toc
toc way qu'elle a ses rites à qui ça
rita est acquis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très mal ou non pas déguisé je sais ça
c'est qu'elle joue sa salle abel et où
les chômeurs sont allés merci à bagdad
faisant il y aura une spéciale kenji
vous le savez le 16 février ce sera
mardi mardi la la vie arrive là avec
kenji et toute l'équipe une spéciale en
live un spécial t pmp que j'aurai la
chance d'animer prophète c'est peut-être
parce que voit juste après mathieu ya
kenji ah ouais ouais
alors je pense que vous avez plus de
chance avec angie avec matthieu deprieck
vous allez me dire locaux avec lui il ya
pas très longtemps il avait une chance
et un ultime chance écologie il est dit
il avait une fiancée bas ça va donner du
sens et maxime mermoz qui apparemment
fait plus de 10 n'est que vous ne venez
d'un week end et celle à celle à qui l
attend
[Applaudissements]
je vais te dire que tu te ressemble
hyper grave est celle des mercis n'ont
jamais regardé ce que vous voulez qu'on
va se rencontrer mathieu du nord
je voulais garder chez vous est ce qu'on
voulait que matthieu delormeau rentrer
tout de suite ou ultérieurement on va
voir tout de suite les résultats du
sondage oui
alors oui bah je sais alors on vous
rappelle deux petites minutes battant
stoke toc
je tiens en plus patrick est un ami un
frère alors deux minutes on voit si le
sondage s'avère ce parce qu'on écoute
quand même là la majorité des gens et
filles de son âge s'inverse
on fera appel à vous le sondeur patrick
mon coeur si jamais je rentre dit le oui
il faut les gens qui nous regardent
de fait laissé leur ai dit tu fais un
truc voilà dit que tu fasses les pires
pour les équipes qui sont derrière
qu'est ce tu fais est ce que tu veux mon
patrick serre entre est ce que tu veux
est ce que tu fais une danse est ce que
tu nous fais là est ce que tu nous fais
une danse répéter pont d'arve tu nous
fais mulenga meurt ça fait longtemps
j'adore me le fais bien de farmer haye
le fait hyper bien oui et farmer quelque
chose d'autre tu veux danser sur quoi et
pour ville du même nom banon mais
coûteuse en écouter c'est gênant non
mais une petite porte et sortait mais
c'est chaud
je sens que je sors
alors on va voir si la tendance s'est
inversée avec ce que vous avez ni herbe
ça ne bouge pas le président a pris ses
points dans les sondages mais thierry
moreau qui est en train de voter la
balle à bocaly pour l'instant enfin
sonné sa place voilà exactement battu
louvion je suis pas venu vois ça fait
longtemps que je suis pas venu
d'ailleurs merci à les remplaçantes
je suis de retour moi beaucoup de votre